Lake is with us in Indiana hi Blake
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up well I started a business
back in 2017 with a partner and I was
the only one who personally guaranteed
Olga loans for the business and the
business has since failed and I've
actually retained a bankruptcy attorney
but I discovered you about three weeks
ago and after listening to you I'm
wondering if I could dig myself out of
this without bankruptcy okay how much
dad and what kind of debt have you got
left over from the business so there's
about a hundred I've got a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars in debt total
fifty five thousand and out his credit
cards that I personally guaranteed for
the business we were a car dealership so
I've got sixteen thousand left over to
my floor plan lender I've got ten
thousand and an equipment lease and
probably another five thousand left over
to miscellaneous vendors and then I
personally have an auto loan and then
what are you owe on your car
twenty-five thousand where do on your
boat eighteen thousand
and what's your income now seventy
thousand okay are you married no okay
single all right yep well in in a
bankruptcy you're not going to keep the
boat in the car unless you keep the debt
right and so both of those are gone in
either scenario all right you sell them
and you get rid of debt or you give them
up in bankruptcy and you get rid of that
whichever whichever whichever direction
you go okay right
the how long are you behind on the
credit cards
I quit paying on everything other than
the truck in the boat in September so my
floor plan lenders already secured a
judgment against me American Express has
just filed a lawsuit against me and so
to discover perfect okay that's good
all right um well you might make it out
of this I mean you sell the boat and
sell the car and your own beans and rice
and let's just pretend that each one of
those that you went to the floorplan
lender and you said I don't have $16,000
I have saved up $4,000 and I'll give you
that if you want take that a settlement
mm-hmm and let's just say you went
through and you settled all of this for
a quarter on the dollar well that'd be
somewhere around thirty thousand bucks
it'd take you and you could probably do
that in making seventy thousand as a
single guy you probably do that in a
year if you got rid the boat in the car
sure um he you know could you come up
with fifty thousand because some of them
wouldn't take a quarter on the dollar
yeah but it's gonna take a little longer
than a year it may take longer than a
year to negotiate with all these people
right right and the emotional stress and
the amount of emotional abuse that you
take through the process is unbelievable
yeah I've kind of dealt with a little of
that already yeah they're just they just
are ridiculous and so what I what I did
I actually had a three million dollars
worth of debt and I had worked it all
the way down to three hundred and
seventy eight thousand before I filed
I almost may I also and that was back in
my 20s and I wasn't as tough then as I
am now and I didn't know then what I
know now so it probably has more to do
with whether or not you have enough
emotional and spiritual gas left in your
tank to fight like a maniac for one year
really hard yeah if you could suck it up
and do that for one year and you just
argue with morons which is what you're
going to be doing it's not negotiating
it's arguing with morons and go and
listen I have four thousand dollars well
we'll take seven thousand dollars maybe
you didn't understand what is English
your second language I mean I said four
thousand dollars that's all I have these
are the conversations you're gonna have
over and over and over again I mean
you're thinking to yourself or your
parents cousins I mean why can't you
understand a sentence you know and you
just have you just kind of have to have
fun with it and you just beat these not
of them because in a bankruptcy here's
what they're gonna get zero right so
anything you give them is a bonus sure
and you're not lying to them you don't
have $100,000 sitting in an account or
you would have not have called me you
would have paid the bills exactly so
you're saying I have $5,000 who wants it
first okay you know and settle each one
of these I would recommend that if I was
going to work really hard on the first
two I would get rid of the equipment
lease and the floor plan people American
Express is all bark and no bite they're
so full of crap you can tell they're
lying if their mouths movie there's a
horrible company and their collections
people break federal law on a daily
basis they're just outrageous yeah and
so you have to learn to just hang up the
phone and have a conversation another
day if you feel your blood pressure
moving up just go they're getting to me
this they're winning this argument I
need to get off the phone this is a
simple conversation I have this much
money do you want it okay as settlement
in full you have to get it in writing
and never give them electronic access to
your checking account because they lie
they will clean you out right but if you
can afford you know how many different
credit cards are there in the 55 there's
probably eight or nine okay and so let's
say there's ten creditors with the floor
plan and the lease right yep
and so there's 10 people we have to get
to come to terms with 10 battles I have
to win and then I win the war right and
if you've got any that are super small
that are like a thousand dollars hey
yeah yeah they're several of those just
pay it and get it out of your life yeah
but if it hadn't been paid since
September you've still got to get in
writing what the balance is or they'll
come back and have tripled it with
collections fees and stuff right right
which a lot of them they've quit adding
fees on to them at this point they're
all going to lawsuits I mean if you had
they're not gonna go if they're small
ones they're not going to lawsuit the
American Express bill must be large
there's two American Express cards ones
thirteen thousand ones eleven thousand
they're north of 10 they will eventually
go to a lawsuit but there's not a lot
they can do with that most the time they
take it - take it - the same thing with
your floodplain company they take it to
you no judgment lien and it just sits
there then if you're wrong my house or
everyone sell a house or something like
that it's hard some of them will go so
far as to garnish wages but almost never
okay now the equipment equipment leasing
the floor plan are more likely to do
that the credit cards credit cards are
just you know they just yep yep yep yep
yep they're just like a barking faced
dog they drive you nuts and so and
you're really not dealing with
intelligent life there this is some of
the dumbest humans on the planet when
you're dealing with credit card
collector sure and you've already
discovered that an American Express I'm
sure and several others yeah yeah and
discover discovers just they're moronic
yeah and so you just have to keep going
listen number one we're not going to
have an abusive conversation that you're
gonna listen to a dial tone number two
there's some basic tenants of the
conversation here's what I've got I
don't have any more you using a
technique it's not gonna make me grow
money I don't have money this is what I
have do you want it bad if it listen one
more time and then I'm gonna hang up do
you want the money and then just hang up
and call back you know five days later
and do it again you know and it's just
you just if you can do all that I think
you can get out of this I don't think
you're bankrupt but it may drive you to
the edge of insanity before you get it's
just you have to turn into a game
because it's such a ludicrous series of
conversations I mean the way they treat
us and we're not we don't even know the
money we're negotiating on behalf of the
customer we're calling up trying to
settle something for some widow or
something one of our coaches here you
know and they're like trying to yell it
does we're like listen you're an idiot
I'm not talking to you if you're gonna
yell we just hang up the phone on them
you know right and they call you at our
receptionist and stuff I mean there's
it's just crazy so it's a weird little
world that they all live in you're
trying to do the right thing give them
some money I think you can work your way
through this if you got enough gas left
in your tank okay okay you need some
help you call me back I'll be happy to
what I'm here for puppy any way I can
been there myself had those exact same
conversations on my own behalf
one reasons I hate American Express so
bad unbelievable yeah they told my wife
one time why would you stay with a man
will pay his bills she called me crying
because she was kind of thinking the
same thing